well he played some warrior chess today
and sam you were the difference between
a national champion and a playoffs
were you motivated at all today to play
as as well as you did
well i'm always motivated every game
just to play my best i don't think i'd
be where i am if i wasn't and i don't
think i'd complained so much when i
played badly if i didn't feel this way
no i didn't approach this game any
differently i wasn't i understood that
it was higher stakes for him than it was
for me but i just played it like any
other game you sacked the queen on e5
and the game got crazy
yeah it was an interesting position like
it was based on a miscalculation
actually i thought i was doing really
well when i first sacrificed i don't
know if you want to see the line but um
yeah so i saw that instead of taking on
e5 i could have played c5 and i thought
it was very close to a draw after dc5
rook d3 and queen d4 it's i'm a little
worse but i thought this should be very
defensible
um but so i thought okay it's a little
uncomfortable and i i'm tired i could
imagine an accident happening but i
thought after queen e5
what i came up with was um
rick d3 queen a7 bishop e1 and i thought
that here i had a very powerful move
rook f8 to keep his king in the kill
zone and then i but i miscalculated i
missed one move i thought here the game
continues with
uh queen c6
rook g3 king f2
rook f4 queen e6 king h7 and here white
resigns and i just completely missed g2
uh i would calculated this line when i
decided to give the coin and here i
thought i was winning i know after rook
two two i can resign it's just over
dear uh so once i realized that i was
like well there goes my queen uh so
but luckily it's i mean you can still
tell i i i'm not even a pawn down yet
and i get to take a lot of his king's
side so there was a lot of counter play
right he did have that chance to play e6
after you played which moment
when you when you play when he played
rook d1 e6 was good i i mean i have no
idea i was barely even right no right
here no johnny without work d1 yes so
yeah rick c1 c5 everything is right yeah
so what happens after e6 puts you in the
in the zugzwung after c4 he plays e5 he
needs that i know but i have to play
rookie g3 here of course i just i wasn't
i mean but then he takes on c5 is this
good for him after rook g1 and record g5
they plays queen f8
is that winning if i i mean engines give
them a big edge okay
i thought this was totally unclear i
give a check on g2 i take the e6 pawn as
king is wandering i mean i've got two
connected passers in the long run
i don't know i thought this was just
totally unclear but
because if he plays queen f5 check and i
go
rookie g6 rook c6 i can go bishop f6 e5
and
rook g5 was what i had calculated during
the game i just thought this was
massively unclear i mean maybe i'm just
lost but like his king is going to be
wandering forever and
i've got i've got passers of my own at
some day i mean i i just thought this
was unclear what lion gives queen f5
rook g6 and an e5 you said
i was saying that rick i don't lose
immediately to rook c6 was my point i
mean i don't know e5 yeah this is the
best move and then say i go like rook
rook two g5 i mean is this sorry sorry
guys uh so right here this is the
position it was you had everything right
yes okay
rook g3 rook c5 no no no no no no no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
no no
check checks check first and then
ricochet five queen f8 and
say yeah
not great
queen i think i give a check i take e6 i
don't know i guess the computer says i'm
lost in d3 and it takes queen f5 check
yeah rick eg6 and then apparently after
e5
uh which is better than rook c6 which i
was sort of worried about and we go back
to g5 i mean i guess apparently white's
good if the computer says so but this
struck me as totally unclear during the
game
yeah it's giving a big edge to white
right now but maybe uh it's mishandling
it
no i mean this is just straight
calculation computer will be right and
what and why you're why not what because
after bishop f6 e5 i can go rook g5
gotcha okay that is
during the game here black's probably
better no i mean he should take one of
my rooks exactly no even though he's my
he might be worse there actually but
okay no it's yeah so it's just wild at
the ends um
yeah i didn't play great tournaments but
at least i i played an interesting game
in the last round
you are going to riga no i'm i'm going
home i mean
so many players are done i've spent 13
days at home since may i mean i felt a
little droopy in the sink field cup and
then i had three tournaments in a row
after that and then further more like
when you're tired you just you want to
catch a break at some point and between
these three tournaments i had four extra
blacks so it's just
you just it's just been a lot and i'm
looking forward to going home
at some point i was worried i'm just
gonna crash and burn this tournaments
but i at least i managed to sort of hold
things together stay a bit over 2700 and
you know i think when i'm rested and
full of energy i'll play a lot better
than this and hopefully
have a chance to fight for first if plus
two makes it i mean yeah
home sweet home that word sometimes
sounds very good well good finish and
good luck in your future tournaments
thank you
indeed sam all the best uh what a game